im antarktischen ozean ist eine
gigantische eisfreie fläche mitten im
packeis entstanden so groß achtung wie
niedersachsen dieses riesige loch im eis
stellt die wissenschaft vor einige räte
und es wird wohl dramatische globale
klima effekte haben es wird jetzt noch
wärmer was jetzt passiert in klicks um
science-fiction herzlich willkommen
normalerweise befindet sich dort im
mittelmeer vor der antarktis packeis
eine dicke undurchdringliche schicht
doch die messdaten dass die kommt johann
satellites aus japan haben schon im
letzten jahr bei 64 grad süd und 3 grad
ost auf der landkarte etwas merkwürdiges
entdeckt ein gigantisches loch im eis
eine sogenannte polen her
der fachbegriff kommt aus dem russischen
und meint eine wasserfläche die entweder
komplett frei von eis ist oder nur mit
sehr dünnem eis gelegt ist und dass eben
in einer umgebung die ansonsten aufgrund
der temperaturen zugefroren ist
es ist nicht das erste mal dass
forschungsteams in dieser region in der
die temperatur im zweistelligen
minusbereich liegt eine solche polynja
entdeckten bereits im jahr 1980 wurde
eine gigantische freie eisfläche im
weddellmeer erstmals wissenschaftlich
beschrieben die akte aktuelle polen jahr
hatte anfang der letzten woche eine
maximalgröße von rund 49.000
quadratkilometern mitte der woche war
sie dann mit knapp 40.000
quadratkilometern etwas kleiner geworden
trotzdem wird sie erhebliche
konsequenzen haben mittlerweile weiß man
sehr gut über die entstehung einer
solchen polen ja bescheid grob gesagt
gelang tiefenwasser das zwei bis drei
grad wärmer ist als das
oberflächenwasser nach oben
seine wärme gibt es dort dann an die
atmosphäre ab und es bildet sich neues
mehr als der großteil des zuvor im
wasser gelösten salzes wird in den ozean
abgegeben ein drittel des salzes geht
aber nur in das meereis über das sich
neu bildet und durch die menge an salz
in den oberen wasserschichten verändert
sich seine dichte ist wird schwerer und
sinkt ab die polynja wird so offen
gehalten das eis verschwindet und dieser
effekt verstärkt sich doch warum
überhaupt gelangt das tiefenwasser nach
oben so dass er gerade beschriebene
effekt ausgelöst wird das liegt an den
geografischen gegebenheiten der region
dort befindet sich ein unter seelisches
gebirge rund
1500 meter hohe berge liegen etwa 500
kilometer vor der antarktischen küste
das wasser in dieser region ist fünf
kilometer tief kräftiger wind wirbelt
die meeresströmungen durcheinander und
bringt so die schichtung des ozeans
durcheinander normalerweise befindet
sich warme sehr salzhaltiges wasser in
den unteren schichten das antarktische
bodenwasser doch im bereich der gebirge
gelangt es an die oberfläche klima und
polarforschung steens weltweit sind
fasziniert und beschäftigen sich
intensiv mit der polin ja also erstmal
hat dieser effekt nichts mit dem
klimawandel zu tun aber seine folgen
spielen dem klimawandel in die karten
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
von der university of pennsylvania in
philadelphia haben intensiv die
klimatischen effekte der eisfreie fläche
untersucht mit hilfe von simulationen
und computermodellen konnten sie zeigen
wie effektiv der ozean
solch ein fehlen der eisbedeckung nutzen
kann um wärme loszuwerden quasi wie ein
überdruckventil an einem schnellkochtopf
und diese wärme gelangt dann in die
atmosphäre der süd ozean ist ein
wichtiger globaler wärmespeicher auch
wenn er nur etwa 30 der weltweiten
meeresfläche ausmacht ist der enorm
wichtig etwa drei viertel der wärme und
etwa die hälfte des gesamten
kohlendioxids das von den ozeanen
insgesamt aufgenommen wird gehen auf
seine kappe dennoch erwärmt er sich
vergleichsweise langsam eine derart
große vollen jahr ermöglicht es dem
meerwasser wärmeenergie an die
atmosphäre abzugeben die situation des
amerikanischen forschungsteams zeigt
dass sich dadurch nicht nur die
unmittelbare umgebung sondern die
gesamte südliche hemisphäre erwärmt also
die südliche halbkugel erdhalbkugel und
noch viel krasser das ganze führt dann
zu einem dominoeffekt dazu die
verantwortliche forscherin irina marinov
die klimamodelle deuten darauf hin dass
in den jahren und jahrzehnten mit einer
großen polen ja sich die gesamte
atmosphäre weltweit erwärmt sich die
winde in der südlichen hemisphäre
verändern und eine verschiebung im
äquatorialen regengüsse stattfindet
zitat ende
auf den punkt gebracht heißt das also
dass sich die polen ja wohl weltweit
aufwinde regenfälle und temperaturen
auswirken wird und
das nicht zu knapp die
computersimulation zeigen dass es
dadurch weniger passatwinde gibt die
wiederum weiträumig die entstehung von
wolken stürmen und niederschlägen
beeinflussen die niederschläge verändern
sich durch einen polen ja sogar
langfristig so genannte regen gürtel
nehmen für 20 bis 30 jahre eine neue
position ein
bevor sie sich wieder zurück verlagert
dadurch sind wasserressourcen in afrika
und indonesien beispielsweise betroffen
computermodelle legen nahe dass solche
gigantischen löcher im eis regelmäßig in
der natürlichen klimavariabilität
auftauchen
sie vermuten sogar dass tollen jahres
durch die globale erwärmung
möglicherweise sogar seltener werden
könnten
denn durch den menschengemachten
klimawandel schmilzt das meereseis und
weniger heiß bedeutet natürlich auch
weniger fläche in der löcher entstehen
können und die meeresoberfläche wird
kühler und wird dadurch leichter
somit ist die wahrscheinlichkeit kleiner
das wärme aus den tieferen
wasserschichten nach oben gelangt und
dort für eine eisfreie fläche sorgt hier
bei pixum halten euch natürlich auf dem
laufenden zu dem thema wenn ihr kein
video dazu und zu allen anderen themen
verpassen wollt dann drückt mir hier ein
abo auf sauber und vergessen sich den
genau auf die glocke und hier geht es
weiter also hiermit klimawandel bewiesen
skeptiker endgültig widerlegt der theke
titels hat sich alles also drauf klicken
und ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran